so taking a small tangent as we talked
about offline uh you have a uh a
background in Taekwondo oh yeah yeah
we'll mentioned Elon Musk I've uh
trained with both this is a quick
question Who do you have uh who are you
betting on in a fight well uh I refuse
to answer that uh I will say this such a
politician you are yeah of course uh
here I'm a politician I'm openly telling
you that I'm dodging the question okay
but I'll say this uh you know I I
actually I spent five years in our
special forces uh in in the military and
we barely spent a minute uh on martial
arts uh actually
learn Taekwondo later when I came to um
it wasn't even at MIT at MIT I think I
did Karate but when I came to the U.N I
had a martial arts expert in taught me
Taekwondo which was kind of interesting
now the question you really have to ask
is why did we learn martial arts in this
special uh Elite unit and the answer is
there's no point if you signed Deanna
Jones you know there's no point you just
no pull the trigger that's simple now I
don't expect anyone to pull the trigger
on this combat and I'm I'm sure you'll
you'll make sure that doesn't happen
yeah I mean martial arts is it's kind of
it's bigger than just combat it's this
kind of Journey of humility and it has
uh it's an art form it truly is an art
but it's fascinating these two figures
in Tech are facing each other and uh I
won't ask a question of who you would
face and how you would do but um well
I'm facing
opponents all the time all the time yeah
that's part of life but you know Part of
Life part of life is not yet I'm not
sure about that are you announcing uh
you know part of life is competition you
know it's you know the only time
competition ends is
death but you know political life
economic life uh
cultural life is engaged continuously in
creativity and competition and uh the
the problem I have with that is as I
mentioned earlier just before we began
the podcast is that uh
at a certain point you want to put
barriers to Monopoly and if you're in a
really able competitor you're going to
create a monopoly that's what Peter till
says is a natural course of things it's
what I learned and uh basically in the
Boston Consulting Group if you're a very
able competitor you'll create scale
advantages that give you the ability to
lock out your competition and as a prime
minister I want to assure that there is
competition in the market so you have to
limit
limit this competitive power at a
certain point and that becomes
increasingly hard uh in the in a world
where everything is intermissed where do
you define market segments where do you
define uh Monopoly uh how do you do that
that is very that that actually
conceptually I find very challenging
because of all the dozens of political
of economic reforms that I've made the
most difficult part is the conceptual
part once you have you've ironed it out
and you say here's what I want to do
here's the right thing to do then you
have a practical problem of overcoming
Union resistance political resistance
press calumny uh uh you know opponents
from this or that corner that's a
practical matter but if you have it
conceptually defined you can move ahead
to uh reformed economies or reform
education or reform Transportation fine
in the question of uh The Growing Power
of large companies
big tech companies to monopolize the
markets because they're better at it
they provide a service they provide it
at lower cost uh it rapidly declined
costs where do you stop where do you uh
where do you stop in a monopoly power is
a crucial question because it also
becomes now a political question if you
amass enormous amount of economic power
which is information power
you know that also monopolizes the
political process which creates these
are real questions that are not obvious
I don't have an obvious answer because
as I said as a 19th century Democrat
these are questions of the 21st century
which people should
begin to think do you have a solution to
that
the solution of monopoly's growing
arbitrarily unstoppably in power and
economic power and therefore in
political power I mean some of that is
regulation some of that is competition
you know where
to put to draw the line
it's not breaking up a t you know it's
not that simple
well I believe in the power of
competition that there will always be
somebody that challenges the big guys
especially in the space of AI the more
open source movements are taking hold
the more the little guy can become the
big guy so you're saying basically the
regulatory the the regulatory uh
instrument is the market
in large part in most part that's the
hope maybe I'm a dreamer that's been in
many ways by policy up to now okay that
the best regulator
uh is the market the best regulator in
economic uh in economic activity is the
market
and the best regulator in political
matters is a political Market that's
called elections that's what that's what
regulates you know you have a lousy
government uh and people make lousy
decisions well you don't need uh you
know the wise men raised above the uh
you know the the masses to decide what
is good and what is bad let the masses
decide let them vote every four years or
whatever and they throw you up by the
way it happened to me there's life after
political and death there's actually
political life I was re-elected five or
six times and this is my sixth term so
you know that I believe in that I'm not
sure
I'm not sure that in economic matters in
the geometric growth of tech companies
that you'll always have the little guy
the Nimble mammal that will come out and
slay the dinosaurs or overcome the
dinosaurs uh which is essentially what
you said yeah I wouldn't count out the
little guy you wouldn't count out the
loom well I hope you're right